well turning now to the growing crisis
over ukraine our david martin reports
that some russian troops have moved out
of assembly areas near the border with
ukraine but are not yet in attack
positions u.s officials believe they
could invade within days president biden
and ukraine's president zielinski spoke
yesterday and agreed to pursue both
diplomacy and deterrence uija jang is at
the white house luigi good morning good
morning to you michelle and good morning
to everybody on that phone call
ukrainian president zielinski invited
president biden to ukraine saying it
would be a powerful signal and could
help contribute to de-escalation now
that call followed mr biden's
conversation with russian leader
vladimir putin over the weekend which
failed to yield a breakthrough while the
white house stresses that a diplomatic
path remains open officials also say
that an invasion could happen at any
moment sources tell cbs news the biden
administration is preparing to withdraw
all u.s personnel from keeve within the
next 12 to 36 hours on face the nation
national security adviser jake sullivan
warned that the russians could be
devising a plan that includes framing
ukraine for starting a war
we also are watching very carefully for
the possibility that there is a pretext
or a false flag operation
to kick off the russian action in which
russian intelligence services conduct
some kind of attack on russian proxy
forces in eastern ukraine or on russian
citizens and then blame it on the
ukrainians
nato allies are also trying to hammer
out a diplomatic solution today the
german chancellor heads to ukraine
before going to moscow tomorrow vlad
the entire world holding their breath
luigi jang for us at the white house
wija thank you